Rusia celebrando unas elecciones presidenciales
suena como Corea del Norte celebrando el día
de la paz.
Un oxímoron. Sin embargo, al menos sobre
el papel, este año 2018, los rusos tendrán
la oportunidad de
elegir si quieren volver a tener a Vladimir
Putin durante 6 años más.
Esto significa que si Putin ganara
estos comicios, sería el líder que más
tiempo ha pasado dirigiendo los designios
del país, sólo superado
por Stalin.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando. Que es muy
injusto decir que Putin es un dictador cuando,
en realidad, se
está presentando a unas elecciones junto
a otros siete candidatos. Sí, sí, habéis
oído bien. En estos
comicios vamos a tener nada menos que ocho
aspirantes al título de Presidente de la
Federación Rusa.
¿El problema? Que ninguno de los opositores a Vladimir Putin tiene la más remota posibilidad
de ganar.
Según todas las encuestas de intención de
voto, Putin tiene una popularidad de entre
un 70 y un 75%. El
siguiente en el ranking de popularidad a duras
penas roza el 15%. Se trata de un señor que
se llama
VLADIMIR ZHIRINOVSKY y que se presenta a las
elecciones con anuncios como este.
“Si me convierto en presidente, este trineo
volverá a andar… ¡Vamos! … Apenas se
mueve … ¡No puede
caminar! ¡Nuestro país entero está parado!…
¡Arre! … ¡Vamos! “ZHIRINOVSKY, TODO
IRÁ MEJOR”
… No hace falta añadir nada más.
Veréis, os voy a dar un consejo por si alguno
de vosotros quiere llegar a ser dictador de
su país. El
secreto de un buen régimen autoritario consiste
en dar la impresión de que hay elecciones
libres. Incluso
en Corea del Norte se celebran elecciones
parlamentarias cada cuatro años. Y, por supuesto,
hay distintos
partidos políticos que se presentan ¡Pero
no os equivoquéis! Que haya varias alternativas
al poder
establecido no significa, ni mucho menos,
que el dictador de turno no tenga un poder
absoluto ¡Para nada!
El truco está en que los otros partidos,
o los otros candidatos, no tengan ninguna
posibilidad. Bien
porque no les conoce ni su padre o bien porque
la propia ley no les deja hacer campaña.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué pasa si, a pesar
de todo, surge un político con suficiente
apoyo popular como para
desafiar al gran líder? Pues bien, ese es
el ejemplo de ALEXEI NAVALNY; la pesadilla
de Vladimir Putin.
Habéis oído bien, cuando parecía que no
existían alternativas políticas en Rusia,
Navalny ha aparecido
como ese gran líder capaz de aglutinar a
todas las distintas fuerzas de la oposición.
Y como os decía
antes… ¿Qué es lo que haces cuando eres
el dictador de un país y te surge un candidato
que te puede hacer
frente? Pues… esto.
El candidato crítico con el Kremlin, Alexey
Navalny estará vetado en la carrera presidencial
Sin embargo… incluso Putin tiene que tragarse
tragarse sus palabras en algún momento. Y los apoyos
de Navalny son
suficientes como para que no esté del todo
claro que no pueda presentarse a las elecciones.
Así que la
pregunta que nos deberíamos hacer es ¿Quién
es y qué defiende realmente Navalny? Y, por
por supuesto ¿Tiene
posibilidades reales de hacerle frente a Putin? Hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes, vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
UN WIKILEAKS PERSONAL
Una cosa hay que reconocerle a Navalny, como
estratega político no tiene precio. En un
país donde los
disidentes políticos tienen la costumbre
de morir jóvenes, este hombre ha sido capaz de
sortear todas las
leyes rusas con maestría de cirujano.
En el año 2008, Navalny era un abogado con
cierto prestigio que tenía ahorrados unos
300.000 rublos de la
época, que vendrían a ser unos 13.000 dólares
¿Y qué hizo con ese dinero? Pues comprar
participaciones de
grandes empresas rusas. Esos gigantes rusos
como GAZPROM, ROSNEFT o LUKOIL son completamente
opacos y es
muy difícil acceder a sus libros de cuentas.
Sin embargo, al tener unas pocas acciones
de estas
compañías, Navalny podía asistir a las
reuniones de accionistas y acceder a información
que estaba
prácticamente oculta para el resto de los
mortales. Así es como Alexei Navalny descubrió
todo tipo de
tramas de corrupción. Tramas que, como ningún
medio se atrevía a publicar, se podían leer
a través de su blog
blog, que pronto se convirtió en algo mucho
más popular en Rusia que el propio Wikileaks.
El Wikileaks ruso de un solo hombre descubre
un fraude masivo en una compañía de gas
Durante los años siguientes, el blog de Navalny
y, más tarde, su canal de youtube, revelaron
las
vergüenzas más ocultas de los oligarcas
rusos. Pelotazos inmobiliarios de empresas
rusas en Hungría,
malversación de fondos y tráfico de influencias.
A la vez que su blog se volvía popular, y
su canal de YouTube
ganaba casi 2 millones de subscriptores, Navalny
sacó toda clase de plataformas para que los
ciudadanos
pudieran reportar pequeños casos de corrupción.
Y, creedme, en lo que a corrupción se refiere,
Rusia da
para llenar una enciclopedia entera.
¿Y qué es que lo que haces cuando te has
convertido en el héroe de la lucha anticorrupción?
Pues… te
metes en la política oficial.
La campaña de Navalny trae un nuevo estilo
a la política rusa
Sin embargo, a diferencia de otros políticos,
Navalny no se limitó a afiliarse a un partido.
Este hombre
es algo así como un Elon Musk de la política.
En su trayectoria ha creado o participado
en 3 partidos
distintos y ha fundado incontables movimientos
ciudadanos. Como os podéis imaginar, el Kremlin
ha hecho
todo lo posible por cerrar estas plataformas
o, simplemente, silenciarlas con todo tipo
de fraudes
electorales. Pero Navalny siempre ha tenido
capital político suficiente como responder…
Las protestas para desafiar a Putin sacan
a la calle a decenas de miles de ciudadanos
Los que veáis este vídeo desde España no
estaréis muy impresionados ¿Decenas de miles
de personas? ¡Eso
no parece una manifestación tan grande! Pero
pensadlo bien, esto es Rusia. Salir a la calle
a
manifestarse requiere un extra de coraje.
Así que diez mil personas en las calles de
Moscú o San
Petesburgo son todo un mensaje. Pero, sin
duda alguna, el punto de inflexión en la
carrera política de
Navalny vino en 2013.
La candidature de Navalny para la alcaldía
de Moscú es aceptada tras el veredicto
Al presentarse a las elecciones para alcalde
de Moscú, Navalny estaba lanzando un mensaje
directamente al
Kremlin: primero tomo la capital del país,
después voy a por ti, Vladimir. Y como os
podéis imaginar, el
gobierno no se quedó de brazos cruzados.
La policía rusa se puso manos a la obra para
intentar sacar
cualquier “indicio de delito” que pudiera
servir para impedir que Navalny pudiera ser
candidato. Y digo
“indicio de delito” entre comillas porque,
como os podéis imaginar, cuando tienes el
poder sobre la
policía y los jueces, puedes modificar la
verdad a tu gusto. Meses después de que Navalny
anunciara su
candidatura, la justicia rusa presentaba cargos
contra él por supuesto robo de materiales
en una empresa
en la que había ejercido como consultor.
Exigían nada menos que 6 años de cárcel
para este hombre. Pero
la historia tenía más agujeros que un queso
gruyere. Así que, nuevamente, esas decenas
de miles de
simpatizantes salieron a la calle. Amnistía
internacional se levantó en armas y hasta
el mismísimo Mijail
Gorvachov dio la cara para defender un proceso
electoral justo. Con todo y con eso, Navalny
las
condiciones en las que se le permitió hacer
campaña eran ¿Cómo decirlo? ¡Una auténtica
broma! Para que os
hagáis una idea, su partido no podía poner
vallas publicitarias, ni tampoco anuncios
en la televisión. Y
en un país donde casi todos los medios están
controlados por el poder político, Navalny
estuvo
prácticamente silenciado en radios, periódicos
y televisión. Sin embargo y pese a todo…
consiguió arañar
nada menos que un 27% del voto. Por supuesto,
no era suficiente para hacerse con la alcaldía
pero, dadas
las condiciones, era toda una victoria moral.
Y un mensaje muy claro para el Kremlin “Cuidado,
Vladimir,
porque te ha salido un opositor difícil de
neutralizar”.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque ser el enemigo
de Putin no significa, automáticamente, que
seas el adalid
de la democracia y los derechos humanos!
¿QUÉ DEFIENDE NAVALNY?
Rusia es un país especial, con unos valores
muy distintos a los de otro país. Por ejemplo,
esto que veis
aquí son imágenes del anuncio que ha sacado
el Kremlin para animar a los ciudadanos a
votar. En el vídeo
se muestra la distopía en la que se podría
convertir el país si la gente no vota lo
que tiene que votar…
y mirad qué es lo que más temen los rusos.
Por favor, prestad atención a los subtítulos
porque no tiene
desperdicio.
“¿Qué *** hace este tío aquí?”
“¡Soy un gay orgullos de ello!”
“¿!QUÉ?!
“Según la nueva ley, tenemos que acoger
a un gay al que le haya dejado el novio. Si
no encuentra nueva
pareja, tendrás que quedarte con el”
“¡La ley es la ley!”
Habéis oído bien ¡Cuidado que vienen los
gays! Por sorprendente que parezca, estos
mensajes políticos
funcionan en Rusia. Por eso, si quieres conquistar
el corazón de tus votantes, tienes que adaptarte
a sus
valores. Así que, por ejemplo ¿Cuál es
la posición de Navalny con respecto al conflicto
de Ucrania?
“La política exterior rusa debería dirigirse
a la integración con Ucrania y Bielorrusia.
EN realidad
somos una única nación y deberíamos ampliar
la integración”
¡Pero no sólo eso! Navalny ha participado
en toda clase de eventos donde se celebra
la raza rusa. Como ya
sabéis, Rusia es un país enorme con decenas
de etnias y religiones distintas. Los rusos,
como tal,
blancos y con ojos azules, son simplemente
la etnia mayoritaria. Y hay varios grupos
ultranacionalistas
que quieren cerrar las puertas a los inmigrantes
de otras razas. Eso incluye a los musulmanes
que viven
en Chechenia o a los tártaros. Muchos de
estos grupos apoyan a Putin. Otros no. Pues
lo cierto es que
Navalny se lleva demasiado bien con estos
grupos. De hecho, el programa con el que se
presentaba a estas
elecciones de 2018 proponía toda clase de
restricciones a la inmigración.
La gente no está asustada con mis principios.
Sólo les asusta la palabra nacionalismo.
--Alexei Navalny
Pero, sin duda alguna, la propuesta que más
ampollas ha levantado en los últimos meses
ha sido el llamado
“Impuesto a los oligarcas”. Como sabéis,
tras la caída del comunismo, Rusia privatizó
casi todas las
empresas estatales. Pero lo hizo de tal forma
que sólo una élite de oligarcas conectados
al Gobierno se
pudieran hacer con la titularidad de estas
compañías ¿Recordáis este otro vídeo
en el que os contaba el
modelo de privatizaciones de Ucrania? Pues
en Rusia pasó algo muy parecido. Y ahora,
esos grandes
gigantes como GAZPROM o LUKOIL cuentan con
toda clase de privilegios políticos. Sus
dueños están entre
las mayores fortunas del mundo. Y Navalny
proponía un impuesto especial para estas
fortunas que podía
llegar hasta el 80% de su renta. Como os podéis
imaginar, estas medidas han desatado las iras
no sólo de
Putin sino de todos sus aliados políticos.
Por eso, desde que Navalny ha anunciado su
candidatura para
estas elecciones presidenciales de 2018, la
policía no ha dejado de hostigarle. Desde
publicar sus
correos electrónicos privados hasta rociarle
la cara con un spray de pintura verde. Mientras
tanto los
antidisturbios han reprimido todos los intentos
de manifestaciones de apoyo a Navalny. Y por
si todo esto
fuera poco, los tribunales han reabierto el
caso de corrupción por el que querían meterle
en la cárcel en
el año 2013.
Sin embargo, como os decíamos al principio,
Navalny sabe jugar con todos los recovecos
de la legislación
rusa y tiene capital político suficiente
como para que sea imposible silenciarle. A
día de hoy, toda
Rusia le conoce y sabe que se quiere presentar
a las elecciones. Sus apoyos se reparten por
todo el
territorio nacional, no sólo en Moscú. Y
sí, es cierto que, pese a todo, su popularidad
no llega ni a la
mitad de la de Vladimir Putin. Pero veréis,
os voy a dar otro consejo por si alguno de
vosotros llega a
ser dictador un día… Cuando todo el mundo
conoce ya a tus enemigos políticos, meterles
en la cárcel sólo
sirve para crear mártires. Y no hay nada
más peligroso para un gobernante autoritario
que tener un
martir.
El líder de la oposición rusa, Alexei Navalny,
liberado tras ser arrestado durante unas protestas
Así que ahora la pregunta es… ¿Creéis
que Navalny terminará pudiéndose presentar
a las elecciones? Y una
segunda pregunta… lo más probable es que,
aunque terminara siendo aceptado como candidato,
perdería los
comicios. Pero… ¿Puede construir una fuerza
de oposición importante que pueda hacer sombra
a Putin en el
futuro? ¿Qué creéis que pasará? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, si
queréis entender por qué Putin es tan popular
en Rusia, os lo explicamos en este vídeo.
Y como siempre, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a
VisualPolitik para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a
LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo
y hasta pronto.